we go to Ron Johnson the great senator
from the state of Wisconsin we had other
plans of questioning you but you had a
very tight race yourself one of the
questions I I think Republicans are
going to have to ask themselves
regardless of how this night pans out
Senator you were in a pretty tight race
but it seems Republicans in many states
are reluctant they are resistant to
early voting or voting by mail they're
not it doesn't seem to be the case in
Florida where Republicans do vote by
mail they do vote early so my question
to you is if that's the current system
Democrats seem to be exploiting it and
they they run up these big leads before
election day and then Republicans are
playing catch-up the rest of the night
now we have to get better at it Sean you
know part of our problem you've seen a
county map of the United States right
it's all red except for a few light
bright blue dots in the metropolitan
areas you know every State's pretty much
the same way as soy Wisconsin is we've
got blue areas in Dane County and
Milwaukee County you know Madison and so
Democrats have a lot less geography to
cover and so it's a whole lot easier a
whole lot cheaper for them to you know
go go ahead and you know get those early
votes out and and keep harassing those
people to get those votes in we've got
to mine votes in every area of the state
same thing's happening in Georgia so it
is more difficult task but we need to
devote more resources maybe a few less
dollars spent on ads I mean the the ad
spending is grotesque quite honestly I
mean it's just so many ads people start
tuning them out there's got to be a you
know the the theory of diminishing
returns okay we need to allocate more
money to the ground game because we have
a much more difficult challenge than
Democrats because we have to again mine
votes from all over the state
yeah let me let me ask you about this
issue how the FBI on a weekly basis was
warning big tech companies I know you
and Senator Grassley are going to have a
lot of FBI whistleblowers coming out and
speaking publicly and and getting their
testimony but the FBI meeting weekly
with all these big tech companies uh
warning them of a potential hack and
leak operation we know that the former
head of site Integrity for Twitter a guy
by the name of Joel Roth that he's
testified under oath that in fact the
FBI specifically mentioned you might get
information about Hunter Biden but yet
we know that the FBI had Hunter Biden's
laptop for 11 months prior to the 2020
election they knew what was in there
they had plenty of time to vet it and
find out that it was is it was in fact
his laptop and then we're finding out
why would the FBI be warning big tech
companies not to report a story that
they should have known by that point was
true that that was Hunter's laptop top
in other words did the FBI put their
finger on the scale like they did in
2016 in order to help a Democratic
presidential candidate
yes they did and they did it way before
October of 2020. I mean it certainly
starts explaining why we received that
unsolicited briefing from the FBI in
August 2006 they knew FBI knew that this
Chuck grass and I were investigating
Hunter Biden so they're out there
talking to not only us but also you know
these social media companies and saying
you know there just might be some
hacking going on here of candidates
family members and you know who knows
they could take that hacked material and
turned into disinformation people like
on Hunter Biden they were already
setting the stage because they knew the
hunter Biden computers out there they
basically threatened in a veiled attempt
or a veiled way Mr mcisaac you know boy
people that talk don't get in trouble
don't get hurt and so they were just
laying the groundwork in case that
computer ever surfaced to sabotage it by
even they by labeling it misinformation
you know what was their coordination
with the 51 intelligence officials that
wrote that letter that helped interfere
in our election and so there's no doubt
about this corruption was occurring all
through 2020 we had Democrats in
Congress also trying to do everything
they could to undermine Senator
grassley's and my uh efforts so I have
no idea how coordinated but it sure
seems pretty coordinated effort by
democrats in Congress the FBI uh the
mainstream media and the social media
companies
so today if you use the words of Elon
Musk he talked about for example the
very definition of you shutting down uh
dissenting voices It Is by its very
definition election interference we know
that the FBI was telling all of these
big tech companies warning them oh they
they might have these these hack and
leak operations you got to be on the
lookout for it and in fact you don't
want to disseminate information that
turns out to be false now they had the
laptop did they not know after 11 months
of having the laptop now they've added
three years that in fact that it was
legitimately Hunter Biden's laptop and
shouldn't they have known and if they
did know why would they knowingly be
lying to Big tech companies about a
story like that
because they're partisans and they're
tipping the scales and yes they
interfered in the 2020 election to a far
greater extent than anything Russia ever
could hope to accomplish and quite
honestly Sean by giving me that briefing
in August and then leaking it and
smearing me in May of 2021 they also
interfere in the Wisconsin senate
election as well so we've got a real
problem in the FBI but again the the
media and big Tech social media Giants
are also complicit and corrupt as well
this is a much bigger story in just the
Twitter files
yeah all right well Ron Johnson uh first
we're glad you won your race you were
going up a pretty against a pretty
radical uh opponent Mandela Barnes and
that was a big win for Republicans
congratulations we're glad you're there
for another six years thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else